new in theaters this weekend rocket man
Godzilla king of the monsters and mob
what will you see this is your weekend
ticket I'm thinking of changing my name
to Elton that's more systematic if you
deserve rocky man is a retelling of the
life and career of singer-songwriter Sir
Elton John
starring Taron Egerton the movie gives
us the ups downs and song creations in a
cinematic flair fit for the iconic
musicians the Rangers kid one of this is
going I just hope you realize you're
choosing a knife it being a man forever
don't know why I just sing when I was
ridiculous paraphernalia people don't
pay to see which one they pay to see out
soon
[Music]
so pregnant Terran not only Don's the
flashy glasses capes and boots but he
also provides all the singing vocals
luging baby
la lady
the film is also directed by Dexter
Fletcher who is one of the producers on
the recent music biopic Bohemian
Rhapsody which means this movie is for
you if you like music biopics like
Bohemian Rhapsody you like the music of
Sir Elton John or if you like rockets
man that's Scott jib
which of these Titans are here to
protect us and which of these Titans are
here to threaten us so you'd want to
make Godzilla our pet no play with bees
the long-awaited Godzilla king of the
monsters also hits the big screen this
weekend this sequel to Godzilla 2014
follows the scientific team called
monarch as they attempt to understand
and ultimately not get eaten by ancient
monsters who have risen and fight for
supremacy
stranger things Millie Bobby Brown stars
alongside Godzilla Mothra Rodin King
Ghidorah and O'Shea Jackson jr. it's
messed up and what looks to be a movie
you absolutely have to see on the big
screen this movie is for you if you like
any or all things Godzilla you love
seeing gigantic monsters go toe-to-toe
or if you like me think Mothra is kind
of adorable
no just excuse me can you buy some booze
for my friends and I oh there's my girl
this never happened hey you guys want a
party like rock stars follow me and
lastly ma comes out this weekend
ma Starr's Octavia Spencer as the
seemingly nice ma who provides some
underage teens with booze and her
basement as a party space
you're free to do whatever you want down
here but nobody go upstairs
what the hell take a look but things
take a turn for the creepy when she
continues to intrude on their personal
lives calling them obsessively showing
up at their houses and torturing and
tormenting them why my son
II smell just like your daddy spending
time at your house probably something
wrong with me
Ma's made by blum house productions who
recently made thrillers like us split
and get out
so it's sure to keep you on the edge of
your seat this movies for you if a
suspenseful movie sounds good to you
this weekend you can't wait to see
Octavia Spencer be creepy or you don't
trust your mom calling mom oh no no no
no no no no no no this is the most fun
I've had in a long time that is your
weekend ticket what will you see and
check back next week for more secrets
about your pets
oh it is so good to hear your voice Gail
what are you doing how is that not my
grandma
[Music]